et donc ce que je vous propose
aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir changer les
choses ensemble et sur ces grands sujets
j'ai besoin que vous puissiez aussi
prendre part au travail du Conseil
national de la refondation et donc avec
vous qui portez des idées de changement
qui imaginaient des projets pour nos
territoires qui avaient des idées très
concrètes de pouvoir nous en faire part
en les mettant en commun sur conseils
refondation.fr à chaque territoire en
plus évidemment de ce qui est le cadre
national
des objectifs des problématiques et donc
il faut des réponses différenciées il
faut permettre à nos enseignants pouvoir
le faire c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
d'un nouveau pacte avec les enseignants
on va les accompagner mais aussi d'un
fond d'innovation pédagogique qui
permettra très vite de libérer de
l'argent pour accompagner ces
innovations pédagogiques et donc on
commence dès maintenant et sur les
premières demandes proposition du
terrain école par école dès le début
d'année prochaine il y aura des réponses
concrètes et des choses qui changeront
je compte donc sur vous avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme de conviction de force
participer à la plateforme mais
aidez-moi à transformer le pays et dont
nous à trouver de manière intelligente
tous ensemble les bonnes solutions loin
des postures des conservatismes loin des
débats qui sont parfois caricaturaux
mais en considérant tout ce que nous
avons notre part à prendre d'idées
d'initiative mais de changement très
locaux
nous pouvons changer les vies si nous
décidons de le faire c'est le choix que
j'ai fait je serai à vos côtés pour le
faire
envers et contre tous les blocages
vive la république et vive la France